drop a crab emoji if you want to see
Danny drink the juice I know I can't it
meets a boy he's he he playing this he
did a the whole nobody said nothing to
me about coronavirus thing he planned it
Danny to make sure all the restaurants
for sure couldn't grab that you know
that's the best restaurant he's he's
brought me to is Waffle House waffle
you're not gonna get much better than
that yeah I mean that's the Bell and I
love Waffle House not level four but for
him that Amy he's you so you're driving
a Land Rover what is he's selling you
short yeah he's something else sort of
five stars
yeah when you first came on the podcast
we honestly thought that you might have
been hitting on Shane we thought we
thought that you might've already for
Shane you know say that after the first
podcast yeah we got some crab emojis we
were getting some vibes from you Matt we
thought that you might have nice been
playing both sides of the fence we
thought that maybe you didn't leave it
behind the gate the Hyundai listen if I
was gay I would have stayed in prison
I'd have been perfectly happy the gay
guys in prison are the happiest guys
they're there they're really okay with
everything so it's like being in a
women's prison you're like yeah where we
at what are we doing people are done
here drinking crab juice crabs at a lot
of Waffle House crabs
alright let's change finish eating these
crab legs I don't drink the juice
oh are you he's done I know you're Joe
where we at we're about to watch you
drink some crab juice I said the crab
legs aside should we put some jack
in the crab juice yeah a little bit of
Jack should we all right we have another
question here it's just two hours we're
going on two hours it feels like we just
started Danny pick the worst stuff why
would you pull the worst lies at the
worst just long stupid questions just
because you can't read the wallet fine
listen this one not really a question if
it's not a question they don't read that
well yeah read it it's a great caught me
what is it let me know it's not a
question we want to know his reaction to
the comment not really a question hey
Matt I take criminal justice courses at
school and we had to do a presentation
on criminal of our choice most people
chose Bundy the Zodiac killer you know
people like that but I chose you
your life your life of crime from this
podcast just intrigued me so much you're
an excellent storyteller as well glad
you got your life turned around that's
from Antonio fifty three minutes ago
that's good that's good
how do you feel how's that make you feel
like that it's like when the guys that
he's got another one yeah I was gonna
say there and then there's this one five
months ago he's the most interesting
self-centered narcissist I've ever liked
I watched all three videos first two
back-to-back I couldn't turn it off it's
funny that you completely loved the
self-centered narcissist thing I have no
problem with it it's like no it's not
that you don't have a problem with it
you kind of like you push it because
it's true you don't you have to own it
yeah yeah I mean you what could I say
I could sit here and go that's not true
really because you're it everything
about you says something different so
for you to sit there and and and deny
that it just it gives power to the
people that are that are saying it in a
negative light I don't see it in a
negative light you know I own it I know
it's I know it's a thing I know it's
definitely uh it's I want to say it's an
issue you know and in some ways I'm
working on it and in some ways I'm
running with it so you know if I could
if I could tweak it enough that I
actually you know gave a [ __ ] about
other people war that would help but
it's it's it's difficult for me to focus
in on other people without trying to
switch the conversation back to me yeah
it's an [ __ ] thing to do and I see
myself doing it all the time and I'll
walk away from a conversation and be
like God you self-centered [ __ ]
selfish prick mm-hmm
you just had that whole conversation
with this person and every time you you
tried to turn you turned it back on
yourself and I'll see myself doing it in
the middle of a conversation you know
what I noticed about your podcast or not
your podcast but when you went on but
with the last bunch of show Bubba's
always turn the stuff about making stuff
about him right like he's interviewing
you and the Diaco guys are talking about
you whatever and before he kind of like
gave in finally and let you tell the
story I feel like he was always talking
about something like trying to relate it
to himself or talking about something
that he went through and asking
questions it seemed like he was well I
think to being and to I think to be an
entertainment or to be a personality you
have to have a certain a certain amount
of narcissism yeah I mean bubbly
narcissist yes you know but I think
alongs it do you think beau is a bigger
narcissist than you are I hope so I mean
I you know I don't know I mean I
honestly I way to be modest I mean I you
know I honestly if I could change it I
would and I'm constantly struggling to
make alterations to the behavior and
it's difficult and knowing it you would
think knowing it like they're like you
know oh admitting you have a problem as
part of this you know half the battle
it's the first thig Burlison I've known
it I've known it for a long time and
it's [ __ ] difficult sometimes I just
get sick of myself mm-hmm so you know I
don't know I don't know what the
question was
you know do i how was the bubba podcast
I read the Bubba when you went on Bubba
show how many times you gonna Bubba the
Love Sponge twice
I was excited just to go on because I
grew up with big shot I grew up with I
grew up you know he was the Howard Stern
of the South yeah of the Tampa Bay area
I think he worked with Howard Stern he's
good yeah yeah yeah I mean I thought the
podcast was fine I went on it twice and
but you know it here's a problem as to
is it it's a much different format and
it's it's it's a fraternity club kind of
guy screaming hollering and kind of like
this but but but amplified mmm they
really talk over each other they were
you were with a couple of lawyers and
then Bubba
yeah but the lawyers were well the
lawyers were better than Bubba but it's
the same thing it's a lot of cutting up
and that's what people want to they want
to hear and then when you're listening
to a radio program that's kind what you
want to hear but it's like okay but I'm
not one of the personalities here you
asked me here to tell my story and then
I started telling the story and they
keep they interrupt and they laugh and
they choke it it's like you can't feel
like I'm I feel like I'm supposed to get
through the whole story that's what you
asked me to do and you keep interrupting
and it keeps stretching it next in you
know it's three hours I haven't told Roy
gone to his story and it's like I feel
like I [ __ ] up like I thought you
wanted me tell like I can't stop you
from interrupting and talking yeah so
it's like what did I [ __ ] up is it me or
am I not understanding and the other
thing is you go on these podcasts and
like you never talk to the guys like
they got the guy from value tainment I
figured okay woman cuz like even with
you when I got here well the first time
we were here we I got here I sat down
you said okay well here's how its kind
of gonna be and you kind of you
explained everything you know you said
we all will just talk about this just
tell your story how long is your story
what do you want to talk about what do
you think so what's the best you got a
little it was only five minutes but we
had a discussion when I went to Value
tainment I walked in the guy sitting
there he's like hey Matthew Matthew Cox
right hey how are you how are you I was
a great impression of his voice by the
way oh yeah I know
he sits I sit down and I'm like hey he's
like okay well yeah we're gonna go ahead
and roll and I'm like well where are we
this is it we're gonna he's like yeah
yeah I've already read everything on you
I know the story I got you everything
like oh okay so and then boom it just
started time is money
i I had no understanding what was gonna
happen any same thing with with Vlad I
sat down his picture comes on we talked
for maybe a minute or two about about a
release he asked me to sign and I was
like the way it's worded this and this
I'm not quite sure I don't feel
comfortable with this he's like well you
can write this and write fix fix it
however what do you want to write say I
said I just want to say this right here
he's like okay that's fine I probably
thought so we changed a couple of things
so you literally signed a physical
release even though he was on skype so
the camera guy had a release yeah I had
a release with Vlad you know for the
podcast same kind of thing I signed for
not you tainment but you know basically
what they asked you for like everything
yeah
and so you're you're cut almost it's not
like you're signing over stuff but they
act like oh it's not a big deal it's not
a big deal but I've been in the
situation where it's not a big deal it's
not a big deal and you sign and then
later on it's like Oh were you signed
here you son yeah but you said that
wasn't what I was signing you said it
was this and oh oh that's what you saw
and you're like well [ __ ] so I always
kind of read through it and say learning
the hard way yeah I'm not good with this
and and they're like you know scribble
that out and I'm like look if you're
only gonna put it on your platform
you're not gonna sell it for a for a
documentary you're knockin no no no no
it's just for my platform it will only
be up okay great let's say that and then
I jot it down so we had a quick
discussion he said no problem I jot it
down take a picture and then next thing
you know he's like okay let's go ahead
and start boom so really this has been
like probably one of the best well the
test I've been on them even though he's
crazy and it's it's long and it's like
but it's it's more casual and you don't
what's more casual you it's a for me the
value tainment guy was good it was
pretty good too they're bad they just
those guys have been doing it way longer
than I have or them right out those guys
have been doing those like one-on-one
interview type shows for a long time and
they've done a shitload more than I have
that's for sure but you're not sure
they're put yourself in the store you're
not trying to you're not trying to
dictate the story you're like so what
happened you're just like so what
happened next
so what happened
so you get to tell the story that you
want to tell well neither is Vlad
I mean Vlad's not on camera he's just no
but he does no he's not he's asking
questions and he's jumping so if you
have a certain light for me I have a
chronological story that I basically
tell it's my story
you say tell me your story do you jump
from college back to high school and
then to when you worked when you were 50
and then back to and then all the way
back to the beginner you tell your story
if you had to tell your story would you
tell it chronologically yeah these guys
are all some of these guys are all over
the place and sometimes they're asking
questions like so what do you think
about mortgage rates right now the [ __ ]
I'm not the mortgage industry been the
mortgage industry for 15 years how would
I know what rates are gonna do what do
you think their current real estate
markets gonna do I don't own anything I
don't know a piece of property I don't
have any I don't have my my finger on
the pulse of real estate so I don't know
so it's it's it's funny that they would
even think that I would have any idea
that of what's going on well those guys
know what they're doing not only so more
than we do so
next question
[Laughter]